إنه بالكاد ما توقعنا أن نجده ،
ولكن منذ اللحظة التي ركب فيها الأطفال
من
الحافلة المدرسية ،
سُحِرنا بالمبنى القذر ، السلم المظلم للفصل
الدراسي الصغير ، ذاب كل ذلك بعيدًا عن
طريق الجمال النادر لما
يحدث هنا
بينما يتأرجح الأطفال الآخرون و  الرقص
على الموسيقى سانتا تبقي رأسها منخفضًا ،
إنه يومها الأول ، إنها خجولة
وخائفة من الأطفال الآخرين كانوا على هذا النحو
أيضًا عندما بدأوا لأول مرة في
مشاركة أدوات التعلم ، كل ما
يمكنهم تحمله في المركز للأطفال الذين
يعانون من متلازمة داون
هو الوحيد من  إنه النوع والأكثر
تمزقًا الذي مزقته الحرب ،
جميع الموظفين هنا هم متطوعون تم جذبهم
إلى المركز لأنه في حين أن الحرب
السورية قضت على
الطفولة ، إلا أنها كانت قاسية بشكل خاص
بالنسبة للفئات الأكثر ضعفاً
، وتمكنوا أخيرًا من إقناع سارة
بالخروج
من العزلة التي سببتها الحرب.
تعني الموارد المحددة أن العديد من الأطفال المصابين
بمتلازمة داون قد تراجعوا
بينما لم يتعلم الآخرون أبدًا الأساسيات
مثل المشي
وإطعام أنفسهم والتنفس  الملك
أحد الأولاد يلعب
بميكروفوننا ، وقد لا يتمكن الأطفال من
التعبير عما مروا به ،
لكنهم جميعًا يدركون جيدًا
عنف محيطهم ،
ويبدو أنه اعتاد أن يكون خجولًا لدرجة أنه لن
يأتي أبدًا إلى
الناس  لم يكن قادرًا على نطق أي كلمات
فقد فقد كلامه قبل
مجيئه إلى هنا ،
بدأ المركز عبد الله
محمد قبل سبعة أشهر
، وهو ممرض أطفال قضى عامًا
في عيادة الأطفال ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة
قبل الحرب
يدفع إيجار هذه المساحة الصغيرة
من جيبه الخاص ،
ونحن نكافح من أجل البقاء مفتوحًا
، كما يقول مدير المركز ،
ولكن في نفس الوقت لا يمكننا التخلي
عن الأطفال
خاصة الآن بعد أن رأوا
التأثير الذي يمكن أن يحصلوا عليه ومعرفة أن
مئات آخرين
يحتاجون إلى مساعدتهم.
متلازمة داون هي حالة وراثية
يكون لدى الطفل فيها
كروموسوم إضافي كامل أو جزئي ، وهذا يؤثر
على الطريقة التي يطور بها دماغ الطفل
وجسمه التدخل المبكر.  تخفف
معظم تحديات النمو ،
لكن حتى قبل الحرب ، كانت
إحدى المشاكل العديدة هي ضعف
نمو العضلات جميلة الموسى ،
تخبرنا أخصائية العلاج الطبيعي
أنها تقول إن عبد الكريم يجب أن يكون لديه جبائر
لمساعدة مفاصل ركبته
ولكن عليها العمل مع  الصغيرة هي
[ضحك]
هذا يعني أنه إذا كنا هنا
منذ
شهرين لم يكن قادرًا على المشي بمفرده ،
كان عليهم حمله خلال كل شيء
والآن الأشياء الجسدية الشديدة التي
كان
يفعلها منذ سنوات مضت قد وضعها والدا زارا لها  في
المدرسة لكنها تعرضت للتنمر الشديد
حاولت والدتها مساعدتها في المنزل
وكانت تعمل بشكل جيد
حتى سقط صاروخ على منزلهم
وتم انتشالها من تحت الأنقاض ونقل
والديها إلى المستشفى.
يستمر المعلمون في حث
سارة بلطف على اللعب لتهدئتها
مما يجعلها تشعر بالأمان
بعد ساعتين فقط من وصول سارة ، إنها
بالفعل تكوّن صداقات
وهي لم تعد وحيدة بعد الآن
هذه هي المرة الأولى التي تقوم فيها بذلك.
نشاهدها تتفاعل مع أطفال آخرين يربطون بينها وبين
والدها محمد ، وتقول
إنها عاطفية بوضوح إنها لا تزال خجولة معنا ، لكنها تقول إنني
سعيد وأهرب للعب في الخارج
إذا أتيحت لهم للتو الفرصة التي
يمكن أن يكبروا بها هؤلاء الأطفال لتحقيق حربهم المحتملة
لن يوقفهم
هذا ما يحلم به البالغون هنا هو
ما يرون أن الأطفال
المصابين بمتلازمة داون يفعلونه في أجزاء أكثر تطورًا
من العالم
لكنهم على الأقل خلقوا مساحة
لا يوجد فيها وصمة
عار مساحة حيث يوجد الفرح والأمل
أروى  ديمون سيينا مدينة ادلب سوريا